speaking of amazing Roger stone is
entering the studio the great Roger
stone
Roger welcome welcome back very well
dressed Roger stone have you ever not
dressed properly for do you wake up in
the morning ready for anything in terms
of your dress because I could imagine
that if you kind of stumbled on let's
say you didn't plan on coming here and
this was a last-minute thing and you
weren't dressed for it it could be very
embarrassing for you well on the other
hand there's no proscribed outfit for a
morning radio show you guys look fine if
you're not wearing suits no but it's
part of your brand if I don't show up
wearing a suit they say maybe that
wasn't really Roger stone right do you
when they make fun of your outfits are
you offended by that no that just people
with no taste you find that to be true
yeah because they think I saw one I
think it was from one of the Alex Jones
shows that you did and you had like a
black beret and black sunglasses on and
people were calling you a cat burglar
and just going nuts and well that was a
homage to Bobby Seale and Huey Newton I
had a black leather jacket a black
turtleneck black shades and a black
beret it was also I had to jump on the
air quickly as I was doing a last-minute
fill-in for somebody else so I'm talking
about I did have time to pull it
together right right yeah that was meant
that was a homage people just didn't get
they didn't at the inauguration mm-hmm
you know I wore ya the traditional
morning sue if you go to the etiquette
book it tells you that for the
inauguration president this is the
prescribed outfit and that was like a
jacket with tails
it's a Swallowtail jacket with tails a
gray vest a soft collar shirt striped
tie and so on every president until
George Bush wore this outfit George HW H
to break the trend son
so Reagan Carter you know so on
Roosevelt Truman and you were trying to
bring it back
I was trying but it was obviously a
one-man effort unsuccessful yeah and
then he's supposed to wear a white tie
tail and white tie to the inaugural
balls that didn't work either men were
wearing what they call tuxedos dinner
jackets right completely inappropriate
but it beats a you know a t-shirt you
wore what you were supposed to wear
though yes of course yeah now where is
there
the book is there it is there an actual
book well there are but the few books
that have been written on this are
mostly badly out-of-date I have a book
coming at the end of November called
stones rules of style no that kind of
tells the young man everything he needs
to know about buying taking care of and
showcasing you know the proper attire
looks good I think a lot of people could
use that a lot of people will walk
around here looking like slobs these
days well the key to it is just always
be dressed appropriately for the
activity that you're about to undertake
in other words if you're going bowling
don't wear a suit if you're going to the
grocery store don't wear workout
clothing have you but you end up showing
up in places sometimes overly do you
would you rather overdo it or under do
it
just remember stones rules can't tell me
you can never be overdressed I said only
be under drew I see so that's safe then
I understand now today is a big day for
you
well maybe we'll say today is the day
theoretically
that all these whatever it is 30,000 JFK
related documents are supposed to be
released you know the law was passed 25
years ago today yes by Bush right that I
signed by Bush I think reluctantly see
the JFK movie right by Oliver Stone
caused a great public interest to return
to the assassination it was on the was
as a reaction to that that the Congress
passed the 1992 JFK Records release act
and the first tranche of documents that
they thank you very much that they
released was very interesting we found
out a lot of things we didn't know what
was stuff in that firt in that for
example we have a memo from J Edgar
Hoover the head of the FBI to President
Lyndon Johnson that says mr. president
we have learned that the KGB has
conducted their own independent
investigation into John Kennedy's murder
and they have concluded mr. president
that you were the ringleader we have a
letter from French intelligence to
Jacqueline Kennedy was a response
obviously to a request from her they say
that they have done their own
investigation they
there's a book called farewell to arms
and they concluded that Lyndon Johnson
was the ringleader
mm-hmm there's a memo from J Edgar
Hoover to the head of the FBI in Dallas
instructing him to brief George Bush of
the CIA about the activities of
anti-castro Cubans in the Dallas area
the problem with that was George Bush
said under oath he wasn't working for
the CIA in 1963 so a bunch of little
interesting things right just didn't and
it all it really does is raise more
questions right because it's not proof
because you could sit there and say like
well the KGB had a reason to say that
that lyndon b johnson was the ringleader
because they would want america to lose
faith in their elected leaders right in
a sense i mean that we didn't know this
at the time but Nikita Khrushchev took
John and Bobby Kennedy to the cleaners
in the in the Cuban Missile Crisis the
story you've been told that they that
they faced down the Russians right so
question I saw the movie total BS what
we removed our missiles from Turkey and
Italy and a secret deal that was
classified for 40 years so the military
knew it at the time but the American
people didn't know it Khrushchev had
just taken Kennedy to the cleaners on on
the on the missile crisis and you know
he considered him a young kal-el guy
that he could bully there was no reason
for the Russians at that point to get
rid of John Kennedy mm-hmm now what do
you but there would be a reason for the
Russians to simply come out I'm not
saying that the Russians were
responsible there there would be a
reason for the Russians to just come out
with a report that made it so that
people questioned yeah American
leadership right wasn't a public
Reporter this was up oh I see this was
an intelligence document there's a there
is a there's an effort to pin this on
the Russians and the Cubans Johnson says
it several times but I think he has a
motive in that we also know that Fidel
Castro had reached out to Kennedy
through a back-channel French journalist
and said maybe we should sit down maybe
we should see if we could normalize
relations that was in the works the time
Kennedy was killed again unlikely that
Castro therefore is involved in the
killing
trol was reportedly surprised but the
diplomat who passed the message there
were two there was a French journalist
in an American diplomat both said Castro
was amenable to a sit-down with JFK and
the Americans at the time that weren't
JFK did not want peace with Cuba there
the the military-industrial complex the
deep state the American war machine
they were ad they wanted an invasion of
Cuba I think and they may have wanted
World War 3 with the Russians they were
very belligerent good god we've got to
get rid of Jack Kennedy he's for peace
as we talk here at about 9:30 5:00
Eastern Time on the day that these
documents are supposed to be released
what are the odds that we're gonna see
them are they pretty good oh I think
we're going to see documents the odds
however are overwhelming that the
National Archive will do what they did
in July when they put out a small batch
of documents I think as a test so much
of it was redacted and censored and held
back that it's meaningless so you don't
think any questions will be answered
well it's I put it this way I think the
Central Intelligence Agency bureaucrats
have got to figure out a medium course
here because the president wants
disclosure if they hand him thirty one
hundred pages which are incomprehensible
he's smart enough to say this isn't this
is you know your countermanding my order
is this is in essence nullifying what i
decided right show me what's what's
covered here I want to see if it's
really in the interest of national
security
everybody involved has been dead for 50
years so that's what Trump that's trumps
part in this because some people are
saying that Trump is getting too much
credit for this because you know it's
it's the law it was gonna be exposed
regardless of who the president is
here's how the law reads yes the release
was scheduled for October 26th unless
the president decides to delay it he
alone has the authority to knock it back
for another 25 years which he could have
done Barack Obama prevented the release
of some of the Bay of Pigs documents on
the basis of national security people
were scratching their heads this was
over 50 years ago what could possibly be
the big secret
well that's that's the question right
that did
is there a feasible explanation in your
head as a skeptical person yes that
there would be a national security risk
to putting these documents out aside
from no I assigned from this is a truth
that that we don't want the American
people to know here is the reason that I
think they want to redact and censor the
material in 1963 the CIA was doing the
same thing they do today
lying covering up and going out and
trying to foment trouble around the
globe you've seen the the intelligence
agencies leaked illegally about about
President Trump I mean he has a phone
conversation with a foreign leader he
turns around and reads it on page 1 of
The Washington Post so I think it's
their methods and their track record
that they don't want people to focus on
these the people who told us Saddam
Hussein definitely has weapons of mass
destruction there's no torture going on
at Abu gorab prison I mean this list
goes on and on and on so this is not
even necessarily because we don't want
them to know that this was an inside
whatever this is a matter of just we
don't want them to stop trusting the CIA
right exactly so it's not that we're
gonna learn anything specific I suspect
that the Kennedy assassination will be a
murder mystery in which people will
always be fascinated and I'm not sure
that we're ever gonna reach a national
consensus but it's interesting to me
that with mainstream media propping up
the whole Warren Commission and oswald
did it narrative for over 50 years
74% of the american people in a poll say
they don't believe it right they don't
think he did it and they don't think he
acted alone well it's a tough one I mean
and I argue this is Troy is a big
conspiracy guy and he digs into these
things and I argue a lot of them but the
JFK one is one where it becomes really
difficult at a certain point to just
believe even if you don't want to dive
all the way in it becomes pretty
difficult to just believe it was as
cut-and-dry here's an example we know
from the FBI reports that came
originally from the Dallas police that a
man went to all the air charter services
in Love Field of the airport and
inquired about renting a plane to go to
Mexico on the twin
the second hmm in every case the man
said his name was Lee Harvey Oswald but
then when the employees of the charter
services are shown a picture of Oswald
every single one of them says no that's
not all of them said no that's not all
of them okay what does that mean yeah a
second man means a conspiracy you have
two people now it's a conspiracy
couldn't have acted alone if a
Confederate was going around purposely
you know leaving a fingerprints
everywhere by asking for air charter
yeah yeah get away playing presumably
yeah what do you what is the do you
think that did one of the reasons that
they wanted to lay this as far as
possible is because the Bush family is
involved and they're still kind of even
though they're still active I am a
feeling that we have gotten whatever was
of whatever regarding George Bush we
have learned already recognized that
George HW Bush maintained for 30 years
he just couldn't remember where he was
that day just couldn't remember which is
not believable because every American
who was an adult or cognizant knows
where they were when Kennedy was killed
I know I was in the first grade I can
remember it vividly for my generation it
would be like forgetting where you were
when the towers were intact so so what
the first tranche of documents from the
Art National Archive showed us is that
he was in Dallas that day and that he
that within three minutes of Kennedy
being shot he puts a call into the head
of the FBI in Houston essentially to
create an alibi hi this is George Bush
I'm here in Dallas and actually was in
Tyler Texas by then because he had a
lunch speech outside of Dallas he says
three times I'm in Tyler Texas he's
clearly just trying to create an alibi
for the record gotcha so he's sitting
there and he won't stop saying I'm in
Tyler Texas oh hey it says right there
where I am it's convoluted he calls and
says this is George Bush I'm in Tyler
Texas I thought you should know that
somebody told somebody told somebody who
told me there's a young man named James
parrot who's a young Republican in
Harris County Houston and he may or may
not have made threats against the
president by the way did I mention that
I'm in Tyler Texas you know so the FBI
go roaring to this guy
housed James Parrott they find him in
the backyard painting Bush for the US
Senate signs and the guy's bewildered he
has no idea what they're talking so I
think it was an excuse to log the call
and have an alibi
at what point cuz you've been close to
government for a long time and close to
politics for a long time at what point
did you really start to dig into this
and really start to develop your own
theories where you believe that certain
things happen that are not being
discussed as early as 1964 I read this
book called the Texas a Texan looks at
Lyndon and I found out what a crude evil
corrupt unbalanced psychopath Lyndon
Baines Johnson was this is the Kennedy
murder is not his first murder I wrote a
book on this the man who killed Kennedy
the case against LBJ I I tracked him to
15 murders prior murders to cover up
corruption and murder to cover a voter
theft you know it was a staple in Texas
politics in from the 30s to the 50s this
is it sounds like my house of cards is
based I'm yeah I know it's very it's
very true so the agricultural agent
who's who's looking into the Lyndon
Johnson Billy celesta scandal major
scandal where Johnson's taking kickbacks
from this Texas wheeler dealer Henry
Marshall he's found dead on his farm he
shot himself in the head five times with
a bolt-action rifle and the coroner
called it suicide well that's not
physically possible five times five
times yeah you'd think after - maybe -
yeah probably probably just a single one
do you think about when you get into
conspiracy though that I think damages
it is do you get to a point where it
where does it anger you when you read
conspiracy theories when people even
like Alex Jones will come out with stuff
that is not accurate and it kind of
hurts credibility and I talked to Tory
about this all the time when you have
people we're like okay I can buy this I
can buy this now that I don't buy and
then you start to double back on the
beginning stuff like you know what let
me just let me just write off the source
I think I think it's healthy to be
skeptical
government of all sides the government
rarely tells you the truth you have to
approach these things with an open mind
you want to hear a conspiracy I'll tell
you conspiracy theory Tommy Lee Harvey
Oswald killed Kennedy acted alone
there's a conspiracy theory Donald Trump
colluded with the Russians to win the
election there's a conspiracy theory the
mainstream media pushes conspiracy
theories all the time do you love the
way this Russia thing is panning out at
the MoMA way sure is boomerang it's not
not great I mean all of my Democratic
friends yeah say to me why won't Hillary
just go away she needs to just go away
she's made millions she's got plenty of
money why won't she just shut up no I
think she's been particularly disgrace
to the last 48 hours her craps just not
selling anymore so he needs to give it
up yeah I don't know I don't know what
the motivation is I don't know if
there's just a desire to save face I
don't think that she wants to run for
election again in four years I'd be
surprised she barely limped through this
one right so yeah I don't know what the
what the motivation is to stay it in
front of the camera well you can at all
you can have power without being elected
to it in other words I think she has a
very healthy ego and a very high regard
for herself which is interesting given
her track record she just can't give up
the spotlight I really think that's it
when you get brought into hearings about
Russia mm-hmm and about your ties with
WikiLeaks and giving up names and all
that stuff does that terrify you
is it a scary thing when you as an
individual no audio no hearings no not
really because you see you don't have to
memorize anything just tell the truth
right it's really it's really simple now
I would compare it as an experience to
something like I don't know like a
proctological exam it's not fun but all
you have to do is tell the truth and
that's what I did I have no
vulnerability I didn't collude with any
Russians I didn't meet with any Russians
I didn't talk with any Russians I didn't
conspire with any Russians I didn't
coordinate with any Russians
I don't eat Russian dressing on my
salads and I stopped drinking Russian
vodka so I mean there's nothing there
you talked to no Russians none during
the election Hanul and did you have to
give up then I was reading someone's you
have to give up the name of the person
who was connecting you with WikiLeaks
yeah it was it was a little more
innocuous than that yeah on the 21st of
June Julian Assange gives a speech which
is widely covered and he says I've got
Hillary's emails and I'm going to
release them so I asked a friend of mine
who's a reporter journalist can you get
a confirmation on that before I you know
spread it far and wide I want to make
sure this guy is on the up and up two
weeks later he calls me back and says
yeah I checked it out he's definitely
got stuff that's it I was hesitant to
give up that individuals name because I
didn't want reprisals against them in
their job so ultimately I got the
privilege waived and I was able to to
disclose it the committee has kept it
confidential I just don't want some guy
to lose his job because I was doing what
journalists do and also as a matter of
principle right
like that's just maintaining the
integrity of the record well you know
the conversation was off the record you
can say as some have stone you're not a
journalist
really I do a column every day a week I
have a one-hour net-based television
show and Infowars one day a week you do
this you know how that it's not like you
jump on it it goes like that right it's
it's a job so I've written five books
I've written a New York Times bestseller
I have a daily radio and television show
and a daily column yeah I'm an opinion
journalist you consider yourself a
journalist an opinion journalist I'm not
I'm not a news reporter I never claimed
to be but I'm an opinion journalist
right now what is that what does that
mean well I make no bones about because
I know a personality like I would
probably consider you a personality if I
were to be asked well but I guess my
point is everything I'm writing is
coming from a certain point of view I'm
not claiming that I'm not buying gotcha
this isn't news coverage unbiased news
coverage this is its opinion journalism
but your credibility is not to be
brought into questions and that's where
the journal is you still have the same
rule right if somebody tells you
something that's off the record and you
agree to honor that you have to live by
that rule if somebody tells you that
something's on background you have to
live by that rule if you don't people
stop talking to you you start you begin
to lose information maybe
very difficult at that point to do your
job doesn't exactly right and then the
information just kind of disappears yep
it just goes away so what is this story
now are the were the democrats working
with russia to try to make it look like
the republicans were working with russia
i get lost
so quickly it's actually not that
complicated explain it to me though
there was a presidential candidate in
bed with the russians unfortunately it
was Hillary Clinton there's the uranium
deal
there's the banking deal there's the
Gazprom gas deal John and Tony Podesta
her top guys are literally making
millions of dollars in fees from
oligarchs that are close to Putin and
tight with the Kremlin so I've got to
say that the maneuver by Podesta is
brilliant look over there
Donald Trump he's in bed with the
Russians it's distraction it's an
attempt to distract so is that what it
is that like you can't accuse us of this
because I'm accusing you of it and even
if you do accuse us of it it's going to
just sound like you're nine of the board
members of the Russian company that
acquired the patrol the uranium rights
gave a hundred and forty five million
dollars to the Clinton Foundation before
the deal went down they gave a half
million dollars to build personally in a
speaking fee so I mean those are thinly
described bribes is exactly what they
are what about the the emails that came
out of Don junior trying to get to
meetings with the Russians they said hey
this Russian guy knows this hey I want
to talk to him Baba yeah not illegal or
improper you're in the middle of a
presidential campaign somebody you know
remember this came to him through a guy
that he'd worked with says this woman
has evidence of malfeasance by Hillary
Clinton if you didn't look into that
that would be irresponsible now in the
end there was nothing there it afforded
nothing and the more you look at it you
find that the Russian woman lawyer who
met with Donald jr. had no visa to get
in the country but the FBI let her in
that smells like a setup to me I see I
see we got a couple people on the line
that want to ask you questions about the
JFK stuff you want to put your
headphones on so you can hear and you
want to make sure his volume is good my
in Pennsylvania welcome Jim Norton and
Sam Roberts Roger stone is here hey
thank you guys mr. stone yes honor to
speak with you
thank you I loved your last book few
things um
I personally supported it Trump
financially went to his rallies I got a
personal invitation to his inauguration
never happened for America um couple
things I would you hang on it would you
agree with that Roger stone do you not
think that there are a lot of flaws with
the way Donald Trump has conducted
himself as president and it's kind of a
stretch to say that he's the best thing
that's ever happened to America I get
you Mike but I want to I want to hear
what Roger says well the two-party
duopoly has been running the country for
the last thirty years how are they doing
right they give you endless war erosion
of your civil liberties massive debt and
spending and borrowing their big trade
deals that were supposed to solve
everything all they did was take all the
jobs out of the country the immigration
policies leave the parts of the country
unsafe neighborhoods and streets unsafe
so why not try something different
the bushes and the Clintons the
Republicans and the Democrats working
together have failed they've run the
country into the ditch that's why as
improbable as Trump's election was
people wanted something radically
different totally and I'm not confused
by it at all I get it but aren't there
moments now where you wish you would
shut the [ __ ] up where you're like hey
you did not phrase that well where for
instance you'd be like can't you just
jump on TV and say some bad things about
some Nazis and move on from this you
know the problem is that you you're
looking at it in real time
mm-hmm and it's easy to say you know he
could have done this better he could
have done that better we won't know
until you know the fourth year of his
presidency whether he's been successful
or not and you believe you will be I
think there's a high probability if he
will stick to his guns with a reform
agenda and make a few major changes in
the country he could be a very
successful president if that's true then
everybody will looking back at these
idiosyncrasies like his tweeting and say
how brilliant how brilliant that was
it's all about whether you're successful
or not I see I mean they used to say
Mario Cuomo
god he talks over everybody's head he's
so cerebral he can't connect with the
honest man
then when he wins what a genius that
Mario Cuomo is right right okay might go
ahead all right one thing about the
government like Trump is a businessman
he's gonna run it like a business there
should be two parties opposing each
other when we're all Americans just like
a board at a corporation it should be
run for the profit and the best thing of
the stockholders that's one thing that's
wrong with the government anyway the
problem with that of course is that it
is run by one party they just pretend
otherwise there's four tenets two
parties you know look the country's in
such bad shape no one party could have
done this by themselves they had help
Republicans and Democrats I say the sad
sadness because I'm a lifelong
Republican but they're equally
responsible for where we are today do
you think that the President Trump needs
to do more to make people who feel now
like they're isolated by this guy who's
you know this kind of obnoxious abrupt
dude that field that feel isolated the
feel that they're not being represented
do you think he needs to do more to
bring people together because I do think
that Donald likes rivalry the Donald
likes competition that he likes that
there's extremes on either side that
you're there so he also likes to be
liked he wants to be he wants slightly
popular in my and I'm just you know you
know him I'm watching him on television
but I feel like he is happier with an
extreme group of people that really like
him like the Mike's of the world they're
like he's the greatest of all time then
hitting the air Mike then hitting that
middle-of-the-road
and saying you know what he's pretty
good I think he'd rather have a smaller
group saying he's great than a bigger
group saying okay he's acceptable first
of all a bigger group the bigger group
is the ones who put him in office
no I got it but but but I'm not talking
about winning an election I'm at the
concert a larger problem in all candor
is that he gets elected with this
mandate and then he systematically
trusting the Republican Party appoints a
bunch of establishment types who didn't
vote for him didn't endorse him don't
support his policies then when they go
out and publicly
disagree with him he's disappointed I
mean the Secretary of State or the
president's chief economic adviser Gary
Cohn if you disagree with something the
president says tell him right bring it
up internally don't go public with it
that is oil it's inappropriate
unprofessional when Walter Hickel was a
Secretary of Interior he criticized
Nixon on something pertaining to the
Vietnam War fired in 15 minutes that's
the way it's supposed to be
scaramouche II was a mistake wasn't he
well he was a suicide bomber he may have
blown himself up but he took two of them
with him so to me he's a hero that's
actually a great perspective he's a
political suicide bomber and what do you
think of Steve Bannon I like Steve
Bannon I think he's much more effective
in the role he's in now outside the tent
tossing the hand grenades in instead of
inside the tent try not toss them out
I said he's right about the status quo
nature of the Republican Party and a
number of these senators who just like
things the way they are mics are
everybody I'm gonna let you go because
we've only got a couple minutes left
with Roger stone which you can get to
his website at stone cold truth com
and you can tweet him at Roger stone jr.
but Roy over here has been very very
excited about you coming in all week
he's been saying when's Roger coming
back when's Roger coming back nice and
he has a couple questions Roger I
appreciate you coming in man and please
if you can come back sometime because I
could talk to you for hours I'd like to
come back I have so many questions for
you but I only have a couple of minutes
what do you think
JFK's involvement was with wanting to
know what the majestic 12 was about and
wanting to expose UFOs and
extraterrestrials this question comes up
all the time when I speak I'd be
honestly I don't know anything about it
there are a group of people who believe
that one of the reasons he was killed
because he was about to go public and
expose the existence of life on other
planets and interplanetary travel I've
never been able to find any
documentation of it but there's a group
of people out there that fervently
believe it do you believe there's a UFO
cover-up I have no idea you don't know
you would believe it but you have not
seen any evidence that way it's
obviously scientifically possible sure
I've just never seen any so I I couldn't
say sure and what's your thoughts on the
loss
Figgis shooting it's not all adding up
it's just not all adding up there's just
too many unanswered questions and the
difference I think between now and 1963
which is a healthy thing is in 1963 you
had three television networks there was
only one guy there were the cameras that
brooder and his film was seized and sent
to Rochester where they altered it today
you've got all these people would sell
cameras you got all these citizen
journalists we're turning up all kinds
of valuable information clues as it were
to what happened and there'll never be a
point where CBS will say this guy acted
alone he did it he was just not sitting
everybody will accept that yeah do you
it's much more difficult now into 2017
to cover up something that was almost
impossible because of the internet and
because of the first of all if you have
an alternative view you can hook up with
other people who agree with you right in
1963
if it didn't happen on ABC NBC and CBS
it just didn't happen
yeah where's now you can literally go in
your basement and start a TV station on
political discourse for many years and
and that's why they're so arrogant today
because they don't like the fact that
there are there's a robust vibrant
alternative media if you don't like the
big three and the two big cable networks
you can go someplace else yeah yeah I
mean to hit that but it was appropriate
let's go to Mike in Philly what's up
Mike they say a big fan mr. stone I'm a
huge fan I wanted to ask you in terms of
the JFK conspiracy what do you think the
level of involvement was with the Mafia
because we know that the Mafia got JFK
elected we know that they had at that
time they were at the height of their
power they controlled entire industries
and cities we have I've read that
there's wiretaps or excuse me an inmate
with Carlos Marcello the boss of
Louisiana who was connected to Oswald
and Jack Ruby yes admitted in prison
that he had JFK killed yes Santo
Trafficante I'm not saying that they
they had the power to kill a president
well everything every
everything you say is right everything
here you say is correct the the theme of
my book is that you had a number of
powerful entities in the country that
Jack and Bobby Kennedy had crossed as I
said earlier the the intelligence
agencies are upset about the Bay of Pigs
and the Cuban Missile Crisis the mob is
upset because ambassador Joe Kennedy
Jack Kennedy's father got a million
dollars from Sam Giancana which is huge
money in 1960 the Chicago mob and the
mob was breaking knees on election day
for Jack Kennedy in Illinois and West
Virginia and Texas and the deal was that
Kennedy's Justice Department would back
off ongoing efforts under Eisenhower to
deport Carlos Marcello in Santo
Trafficante
two of the biggest crime family leaders
well Jack Kennedy got elected Bobby
became Attorney General and he goes
after these two guys with everything
he's got they were double-crossed so
they clearly play a role the central
intelligence agencies motive we've
covered big Texas oil they're upset
because JFK's trying to repeal their tax
breaks the oil depletion allowance
that's why they financed it and then
there's good old LBJ he knows that there
are two criminal investigations about to
come down on him the Bobby Baker case
and the Billy saw Estes case and he's
going not just be dropped from the
ticket he's going to prison
he knows that Drew Pearson who is the
most influential columnist of his time
has a column in the can for Sunday
November 23rd that says LBJ took a ten
thousand dollar bribe to fix a
procurement contract for General
Dynamics in the txf fighter that column
gets spiked when John Kennedy is killed
because they're not going to take on the
new President Johnson knows the clock is
running out Bobby wants to put him in
jail he's got to move first and he does
who controls the Dallas Police who
controls the Dallas Sheriff's Office who
controls most importantly the Dallas
district attorney because murder in 1963
in Texas is a state not federal crime
which means good old LBJ controls the
investigation from the get-go
why do you hear people saying like oh I
would expose the
truth but I'm in danger of being
attacked or my family being killed or
what you hear that stuff all the time
from people who say they have the truth
but an extraordinary number of people
defying the mathematical odds who are
connected to the Kennedy assassination
have been killed so how come you're safe
maybe because you're so high-profile I
think you say you know if something
happens to me you'll know Hillary
Clinton did it right or whatever right
yeah I would say if something happened
to Roger stone we would be made aware
yeah we will be made aware of it fine
Podesta he did it